>>Zach: Alright, thank you! It's awesome to
be here at the company that, in many ways,
made the production of this book possible
and which has multiple, multiple copies of
the book stored within its vast and comprehensive
archive of all the worlds culture already
whether it knows it or not; thanks to my Gmail
account.
As Will said, I grew up in Montana where manly
men and even more impressive women kind of
run the show athletically. I, myself, as you
can probably tell from my pathetic appearance,
grew up in a sort of more frail, bookish,
inward-looking child. Although, I was always
a big sports fan.
So, from an early age I was trying to figure
out how I related to this world of sports
and outdoor activity in a way that made sense
for me and yet, was also true to my essentially
nerdy nature.
So, a few years ago, in Portland while I was
working as a newspaper reporter, I started
writing about sports. And I, I began to gravitate
toward these sports that were, in one way
or another, sort of a DIY approach to sports.
And, and there were a lot of different aspects
of that in a spectrum of activities that I
felt qualified.
So, that, this book kind of grew out of that
exploration of sports that were outside the
realm of the mainstream, majorly professional
sports; sports that were being done by individuals
in groups, more or less self-organized or
on a DIY level.
So, with that said, I'm gonna read a couple
passages that I think sort of get to what
the book is about.
"It's amazing what you can learn with your
head jammed between two rugby player's thighs.
It was a dank October evening, and I was at
work on a story about the Oregon Jesters women's
rugby team. They invited me out to a practice,
and at the coach's suggestion, I brought my
soccer cleats. I soon found myself ordered
to crouch to the scummy turf, then wedge my
head between the legs of the two players in
front of me. These women, a 'prop' and a 'hooker,
applied a stubbly vice grip to my skull, pressing
from each side in an apparent effort to reduce
my ears to pulp. Then I reached up between
my new friend's legs to grab the waistband
of their grit-spackled shorts. I heard the
hooker growl. 'Grab crotch, not hair,' she
said. 'It sucks when that happens.'
'Okay.' Intimate arrangements complete, we
formed a compact human battering ram, or 'scrum'.
We smashed full-force into an iron sled called
the Dominator. The Dominator looked like something
that would be useful in taking out a Frankish
castle. My face was about a foot off the ground,
and I could only hear barnyard squelching
as we hurled ourselves against this torture
device. Thirty seconds later, I wobbled to
my feet. 'Well done, rookie,' the prop said.
'Well done.' I nodded my head, now smaller,
in gratitude.
The Jesters turf, once grass, was now reduced
to an oozy and foul-smelling black muck. From
here, I could see the outermost edge of the
sport's world. Lacrosse players bellowed on
the next field over. Just across the rugby
field's boundary, two guys were exercising
attack dogs. A few street lamps, orange and
hazy in the perpetual Portland mist, provided
the only light. I felt like I was in the right
place, even though I hadn't expected near
decapitation.
I was writing about my new rugby friends for
Portland's alternative weekly newspaper, which
had drafted me out of Montana to edit its
music section in 1999. Not long after I arrived
in Portland, perhaps feeling that an endless
diet of underfed and emotionally bereft Indie
rock bands threatened to zap, sap the zest
from life, I started badgering my employer
to assign me sports stories. My editors agreed
to let me cover this self-declared beat under
the mistaken impression that I would generate
actual news about sports of interest to the
public at large. I planned to do the opposite.
I covered bike messenger races and adult soapbox
derby. While this direction didn't exactly
endear me to my editors, I felt that I had
pierced the polished surface of mainstream
sports. And that was before the thing with
the rugby players thighs. So, what did it
mean; all this fumbling around on the margins
of sports? I thought I detected faint but
definite tremors, something stirring underground.
Yes, the major leagues now achieved new frontiers
in hype and pomp every season, but what if,
at the same time, a revolution was taking
shape? What if a whole, alternative sporting
nation, a more perfect union of independent
athletes' nonconformist fans, wildcat leagues,
and gorilla clubs scattered across the country
could rise up and challenge the mainstream?
I began to dream big, imagining that a total
inversion of the sports power structure was
occurring just out of sight somewhere near
the rugby practice field. I admit that it
sounds a little far-fetched and dreamy, but
I knew that vaguely similar upheavals had
happened before. If you think about it, major
league sports could be the athletic equivalent
of stadium rock. The production values are
awesome, but the scale is alienating and the
egos are enormous. The bitchy, psycho-dramas
of the Kobe-Shaq Lakers recalled Fleetwood
Mac in full, wife-swapping, meltdown mode.
Tiger Woods once reminded me of James Taylor
in his bland excellence. Now we know he's
more like a less entertaining, one-man, Motley
Crue. The excesses of stadium rock, of course,
inspired punk rock, which insisted that anyone
who could play three chords could, and should,
form a band. Now, I thought, the same thing
could happen in sports. How great it would
be if I wasn't simply crazy. I thought the
raw ingredients for a renegade sports movement
existed, but obviously, they had yet to emerge
as an identifiable, cultural force, unless
you count self-aware, urban twenty-somethings
tendency to form dodge ball teams. Perhaps
I was engaged in wishful thinking, so I decided
to go exploring beyond the boundaries defined
by newspaper sports pages, talk radio, and
24-hour cable. I wanted to see if sports counterculture
I hoped for really existed, or if it could.
As I stood on the rugby field that night,
checking my spinal column, I began to think
I was getting somewhere. If I survived, it
would be fun. So, I started to, I started
to seek out athletes and events on the sort
of stranger end of the sports world. And before
long, I found this bike race in Iowa, called
the Trans Iowa, which is organized by one
man, who's named Mark Stevenson, but who is
known to everyone as Guitar Ted because of
his teenage love for Ted Nugent. So, I knew
right away, before I even met him, that Guitar
Ted was a man after my own heart."
And the Trans Iowa sounded like something
I needed to check out. It was a 300 mile endurance
race that begins at 4 o'clock in the morning
in a small town, leads the participants through
the middle-of-nowhere Iowa farm company, Iowa
farm country for hours on end with no support,
no kind of outside assistance, nothing like
the Tour de France style, cars driving alongside
them with spare bikes and, you know, extra
drugs if they need them. So, nonetheless,
this sport was a, this event was attracting
dozens of participants from all over the country
and seemed to have kind of a little bit of
a, sort of an underground legend growing around
it. So, I went to Iowa to, to track the Trans
Iowa and meet Guitar Ted. And this a little
bit of what occurred.
Hawkeye, Iowa, population 489. At Trinity
Lutheran Church, the sign announces that at
8 am, just six hours from now, Pastor Mike
Horn will deliver a sermon entitled, 'Safe
in God's Hands.' A spooky moon shines down.
I am not wearing pants. Leaning into the passenger
side door, I rummage around inside the red
Pretender, my rented Pontiac pseudo sports
car, fighting the entropic storm of granola
bar wrappers, empty soda cans, separating
gas station coffee cups, crumpled clothes,
and dried yellow-tan mud. I find my thermal
long johns, hop around on the cold gravel
as I pull them on, then step into car hard
cargo pants and hiking boots crusty with grime.
The good people of Hawkeye can now rest easy;
not that local sensibility seemed too delicate.
Ten minutes before, a pickup truck lumbered
around the corner at the tell-tale pace of
a DUI dodger and bumbled over the curb and
into the middle of the lawn across the street.
A woman jumped out and sprinted inside the
house. She left the driver's side door open.
She left the country radio station on, blaring.
The latest Nashville hits now pound through
Hawkeye's half dozen comatose streets. First,
I expect the cops to come. Then I realize
there probably aren't any. Ten yards away,
a man called Guitar Ted leans against his
car, a blue, beat to shit Honda. He's drinking
Red Bull, talking. Since 4 o'clock the previous
morning, I followed Guitar Ted down hundreds
of miles of dirt roads and two lane highways,
with long frequent stops; he's been drinking
Red Bull and talking pretty much the entire
time. 'Man, some of these people in these
small Iowa towns,' he continues, pointing
over at the pickup truck between poles at
his little aluminum can. 'They're bad; I mean
they can get wild. You think these farm towns
would be all nice and quiet and traditional
small-town America, and I guess in a sense
they are, but when the bars close.' I can't
really follow it. I like Guitar Ted a lot.
Caravan with a man for 22 straight hours and
he either becomes your temporary brother,
or an enemy for life. But, Jesus Christ, like
I said, 22 hours; he shows no signs of weakness,
exhaustion, or imminent silence.
Right now, I could strangle Guitar Ted through
his wolf man beard, curl up on Trinity's porch
and beg Pastor Mike for forgiveness and sanctuary,
'safe in God's hands'. This whole thing, pogoing
around pantless in some forsaken hamlet on
a diet of power bars and gas station coffee,
waiting in the deep-freeze for a pack of bicyclists,
for the love of God? Right now, I blame Guitar
Ted. We are tracking the Trans Iowa, a 300
plus mile, non-stop, endurance bike race through
some of Iowa's most beautiful and least vehicle
hospitable quadrants. A race, entirely the
product of Guitar Ted's febrile mind. He is
the race commissioner, course designer, referee,
time-keeper, logistician, and prize committee.
I guess that makes me the press corps. The
Trans Iowa enjoys no sanction from any official
cycling organization, no status with any kind
of recognized competitive framework, it charges
no entry fee, and offers no cash prize of
value greater than the price of a bottle of
whiskey. It provides no support, no course
marking aside from Guitar Ted and, in this
case, me, standing roadside every 50 miles
or so, and operates on a strict 'every man
for himself' basis as far as health and safety
go. It traverses roads that Iowa transportation
authorities see fit to post with 'Enter at
Your Own Risk' signs.
The previous year, rain turned the course
into a mud sluice and not a single contestant
finished. Still, about 60 riders started Trans
Iowa version three at 4 o'clock yesterday
morning. At least a few of them are still
alive and on course. In Hawkeye, Guitar Ted
and I hope to catch sight of the leader, a
rider named Ira Ryan. 'You're pretty much
guaranteed a bar fight at 2 am in any one
of ooh, light,' Guitar Ted points down the
deserted road, past the pickup truck. A tiny,
blinking, white speck wobbles just beyond
the weak penumbra of one of Hawkeye's few
streetlights. Ira Ryan, a bony shard of a
man in a red windbreaker and Lycra tights,
takes shape out of the gloom, canted forward
over the handlebars of gunmetal, gray bike
he welded together himself. Ira is a 30 year
old native Iowan, a professional custom bike
frame builder, a cycling zealot, and by virtue
of winning the first and only completed Trans
Iowa back in 2005, the events current defending
champion. As he blows past us, Ira crushes
his petal with an automatic remorselessness,
steering by glazed stare. Later, he doesn't
remember much about this scene. Hawkeye itself,
he recalls, is a smudge in the periphery,
indistinguishable amid visual hallucinations
of phantom cows and ghostly rival cyclists
and split seconds of lost consciousness. At
this point, Ira has ridden over 200 miles
with no sleep; the brain chemistry gets a
little dicey. As Ira's flashing taillight
fades into the darkness at Hawkeye's far end,
I, likewise, feel delirium setting in. Of
course, delirium is the Trans Iowa's point."
So, I'll let you all discover the rest of
the glory of the Trans Iowa, if you so desire.
But, beyond self torture of this sort, and
Ira specifically said that one of the things
that motivates his cycling career is his love
of the "glory of suffering," as he puts it.
On a less, sort of painful level, a lot of
what this book is about is this sort of joy
of participating in things and doing things
yourself, even if you're not particularly
good at them. Particularly, if you can do
it in a way that feeds your social life, or
enriches your sphere of acquaintances or circle
of friends or things like that. It's, a lot
of the book is about the sort of the social
side of sports and the exuberant joy that
you can find playing games with your friends,
or making new friends through sports. So,
I'm gonna conclude with one more passage,
which is about a soccer team that I was on
about 12 years ago in my hometown in Montana,
called "The Carnies."
"The global soccer explosion, well under way
elsewhere, hadn't quite happened yet in late
1990s Missoula. Social trends tend to wash
over Montana about a decade late and about
half the time, this is a good thing. Isolation
breeds creativity, so my friends and I were
used to making our own fun. Sometimes, that
meant hauling a rented generator down to the
riverside to power a show by an extreme leftist
punk band on tour from North Dakota. All too
often, it meant weekends aptly described as
lost. In '97 and '98, it meant the Carnies
football club. The Carnies wore black t-shirts.
Our team crest consisted of a hand drawn shield
bearing a skull, a switchblade, and a bottle
marked 'XXX.' When I solicited a sponsorship
at a local sports bar, the owner gave me a
blank look and said, 'Soccer, huh? Well, I
guess. We wanna see you guys in here after
every game, ordering plenty of beer. You think
you can do that, buddy?' I thought we could.
I can't say for sure, but I feel confident
that Missoula Coed Division One never before
saw, and never again would see, a team as
awful as us. For our debut match, about 30
rookie Carnies, lured perhaps by the team
captains talk of 'plenty of beer', showed
up. Our sideline resembled a protest against
the World Trade Organization, and every substitution
opportunity devolved into total chaos. If
memory serves, we trailed a well-kempt team
from a law firm 5-nil at half-time. The referee,
a tallow skinned, 50-something character,
who wore a vintage Santos FC warm-up suit
and chain smoked throughout the entire half-time,
strolled over. 'Captain,' he said. 'You've
got to get your team organized.' I didn't
ask if he had any tear gas I could borrow.
We did bag a consolation goal in the second
half. A Carnies striker, one of the handful
of our players with real playing experience,
nailed a scorcher from 25 yards out. A fantastic
goal from any perspective, it must have looked
especially beautiful to him, because he was
on hallucinogenic mushrooms at the time.
As the season progressed, the Carnies improved
a little. A Belarusian man, named Pavel, a
paternal gent with salt and pepper hair who
none of us had ever met, mysteriously started
showing up promptly at game time to play for
us every week. He proved good for a couple
goals a game.
Our pugnacious goalkeeper, a National Guardsman
who both served in Afghanistan and played
bass in Missoula's most venerable punk band,
put a little muscle in our defense. So did
the linebacker from the Montana's Grizzlies
football, the other kind, team, recruited
by my brother who spent much of his time in
Carnies black trying to start fights with
opposing players. Our female players, it turned
out, were much better than our men. For some
reason, the Carnie women tended to be more
physically fit and less lifestyle impaired
than their male counterparts. I don't know
why. Other teams, genuine amateur athletes
seeking bonified recreational competition,
I suppose, seemed unimpressed by our freewheeling
approach to the game. 'This is ridiculous,'
one snotty hotshot whined to our referee.
'These guys don't belong out here.' His team
had just scored three goals in 15 minutes
while dodging homicidal slide tackles, so
maybe he had a point. That didn't stop me
from screaming, 'That was for you, motherfucker,'
when we, Pavel, leveled the score in a game
that we, meaning Pavel, almost stole. The
Carnies put together an immaculate, winless
streak. No other team, however, could match
our party record. About half the core squad,
including me, lived in a nine bedroom, decommissioned
nunnery behind Missoula's oldest Catholic
church. By post-match midnight, a choreographed
wrestling match usually took place in the
living room with Heinz 57 used as fake blood.
We discussed tactics, technique, and line-ups,
but soon enough the day's soccer results started
to feel irrelevant, compared to the olive
oil belly flop contests on the kitchen floor.
Sadly, Pavel never joined us. I believe he
was a religious man."
So that will conclude the reading portion
of today's events. If anyone has any questions
for some perverse reason, I will do my best
to provide an equally perverse answer. But
if not, thanks very much.
[applause]
Questions?
You, sir.
>>membermale1: Yes, you say you--
>>Zach: To the mic. This is being recorded
for posterity.
>>membermale1: Thank you very much for coming,
Zach. You said you remain a sports fan and
I just wanted to hear kind of your take on
the media that surrounds famous, almost celebrities,
or sports stars, like, kind of all the media
around Tiger Woods and--
>>Zach: Sure.
>>membermale1: his slew of--
>>Zach: His incredible conquest--
>>membermale1: Yes.
>>Zach: record, yes.
>>membermale1: Exactly. And, and, another--
>>Zach: I mean, he is a cute guy, but you
know, he's got kind of a built-in advantage
of having so much cash. You know, yesterday
I was sitting in a, in a restaurant here in
San Francisco, eating lunch and they had the
TV on with the sound off and it was one of
these, sort of, sports, sports writer, round
table discussion shows featuring, you know,
these crusty, ancient, dinosaur sports columnists
from newspapers around the country. And they
had a, you know, it was one of these things
that you see on CNN or ESPN, where there's
the four screen, the four sections of the
screen and it's one man's face in each of
the screens and they were all talking. And
I don't even know what they were talking about
because the sound was off. And these four,
old, white dudes were sitting up there like
and they're all talking, they were moving
their hands and like, gesticulating at one
another and you couldn't hear 'em and you
lost nothing with the sound being off. I mean,
it's like, a lot of the-, it's, this is not
unique to sports, obviously. This is a sort
of a plague that infests our culture, but
a lot of the discussion about sports in this
country is just people talking, and not saying
anything. The appetite for sports information
and the sort of commercial demand for it has
grown to the point where 90% of what you see
and hear and read it, about sports isn't really
about sports at all. It's about the business
side of things, or celebrity gossip about,
you know, whatever terrible offense against
common decency that Ben Roethlisberger has
recently committed. And, I, I guess part of
the reason I wrote the book was the desire
to cut through all of that, not saying that
mainstream sports or big time sports are illegitimate,
obviously they have a huge audience, and I'm
part of that audience. But, to say that, you
know, that stuff is not what really what sport
is about. I mean, sport is about experiencing
things, doing things that you otherwise wouldn't
do, having fun, and getting out there and
being part of the world rather than passively
sitting back and listening to this endless
stream of garbage about Tiger Woods or what
are, you know, whatever the topic du jour
is. So, I guess that's, you know, my response
that I would give. The book is sort of an
attempt to kind of like, claw some real meaning
out of sports and drag it away from those
people that are just, you know, jabber jawing
about it all the time.
Miss.
Go to the mic.
>>memberfemale2: I'm just wondering if you
have any thoughts on like, the gym culture,
gym rats, people who like, pump iron?
>>Zach: I mean, I, I've been a member of a
gym and I, I don't, I would never discourage
anyone from trying to be healthy or fit, except
a lot of people think I am with this book
that's all about, you know, terrible, drunken,
mad cap antics. But, I find it a little bit
depressing. You know, I find, I find when
I walk past a gym in any city, I look through
the window and I see ranks and ranks of people
on treadmills with their ear buds in, watching
Fox News or CNN or ESPN, and going like this
[footsteps]
I, I just, you know, it's almost s-, like
a suicidal; makes me feel almost suicidal.
The, and it's kinda, you know
[sighs]
you know, sports are sport or athletic activity,
one thing that is an underappreciated thing
about it, is it's kind of funny. Like, at
least at the level that I do it, the level,
a lot of people do sports on, it's like, it's
kind of ridiculous. I play soccer for this
team called The Unicorns now. We often get
beaten very badly. I am a terrible player.
So, it's, it's, you know, in addition to like,
you know, exercise or staying fit or whatever,
it's also an, sports also provide me, personally,
an opportunity to sort of laugh at myself.
I feel like that unseriousness is lacking
in, in the gym world. It's sort of like, in
the, in the minds of the gym owners of America,
all Americans are like, thoroughbred horses.
They just need to be like, pumped full of
specialty beverages and like, run really hard
and then toweled off and sent back out to
the pasture. I, you know, I mean, I'm, I'm
not saying that it doesn't have a place in
the world, but there's more to life.
>>membermale3: There's been like a recent
in surge, I guess like, increase in organized
competitions of alternative stuff--
>>Zach: Yeah.
>>membermale3: There's this thing called "The
Tough Mudder" in New York where they go on
this mountain that's usually a ski mountain
and there--
It's like, in April so it's really muddy--
>>Zach: Right.
>>membermale3: and you're running up the mountains.
It's an obstacle course--
and doing all this stuff. There's one in England
called "The Tough Guy Challenge" and I guess
it's been going on for like, a couple decades.
Do you see like an increase in that kind of
organized sort of different type of sport?
>>Zach: Oh, absolutely. I mean, there are,
there are, literally hundreds or probably
thousands of sports and events that I could
have put in the book, but I didn't for, you
know, simply trying not to drive myself too
insane. I mean, there's this thing in Tennessee
called "The Barkley Marathon", which is this
like, harrowing sounding endurance marathon
through basically, like, it sounds like, the
world's most inhospitable terrain. Like, there's
this forest of sticker bushes in Tennessee
that they make these guys run through and
essentially, no one has ever finished it.
Just to up the ante, the organizer serves
all the participants a mandatory dinner of
uncooked chicken the night before--
[laughter]
so, anyway, this is getting us off the topic
and into something quite disgusting. But,
I think that, you know, I mean this is gonna
sound like a cliché, especially being at
Google, but the fact that the Internet now
allows people to organize on such a sort of
spontaneous and seamless basis has created
this exponential increase in these kind of
DIY events.
>>malemember3: Do you think, I feel like San
Francisco would be like a great place, there's
a lot, there would be a lot of activity there.
But, what city have you seen that's, is--
>>Zach: Well, I, I mean, solely for the purposes
of my own laziness and limited budget, I did
a lot of the book in my home city of Portland.
But, I think, you know, there's a, there's
a sort of, as I describe them, the "left coast
nerd cities" which I would, I would categorize
San Francisco, Portland, and Seattle, and
probably Vancouver, British Columbia in that
group. These cities that tend to attract and
foster these sort of, I don't know what you
would call them, alternative approaches to
fun and also have a-, enough critical mass
of people that are interested in doing different
things that they, that they spawn endless
numbers of these groups. So, Portland's a
great one. You know, but it was impressive
to see things thriving in places like Iowa.
I went to Austin, Texas for the Roller Derby
National Championships. Austin is like, the
global capital of roller derby. There's things
all over the country, you know, I mean, and
that, that was one really nice aspect of working
on the book is just discovering like, "Oh,
yeah!" Rediscovering, in my case since I'm
from Montana and I'm totally aware that people
in quote-unquote, fly over country, have,
you know, all these weird things that they
do. But, discovering that all over the country
there are these cool events and cool people
that are putting things together. I don't
know if that answers your question, but I'm
done talking about it now.
[audience chuckles]
>>memberfemale4: So, you just kind of briefly
mentioned that like, the Internet has-, allows
people to organize these types of things a
little bit more and kind of gives that access
to more people and also with just more media
in general, like if you get, you know, a really
big TV package you can get channels that's
like the alternative sports or those types
of things.
How ever else do you think, and I don't know
if you touch on this in the book or not, but
some of that mass media also contributes to
the dilution--
>>Zach: Oh, absolutely, yeah.
>>memberfemale4: so what is kinda your, I
guess, opinion on kinda what is that fine
line having media be a good thing to kind
of bring exposure to all these sports, but
then also media being part of the, the problem
in diluting the--
>>Zach: Well, I think roller derby is an interesting
example of a sport that is confronting this
issue right now. I mean, roller derby has
gotten a tremendous, since roller derby was
revived less than a decade ago, it's very
serious, but also, it's an interesting thing.
It's seriously competitive; it has a frivolous
sort of image of women in tight outfits with
weird names, fighting each other on a track
and bands playing at half-time and everybody
getting really drunk. But, it has also spawned
this incredible proliferation of national
leagues, or teams, city leagues around the
country and then national competition and
very serious tournaments.
And yet, most of the media attraction it has
intent-, it has attracted has focused on the
sort of superficial side of its appeal, which
is these kind of rock and roll chicks who
like to fight and beat each other up. They
don't ever, the media coverage rarely delves
into the seriousness and the sort of, the
intense nature of the sport. I mean, if you
watch two of the top roller derby teams in
the country go at it with something on the
line, it's as intense as anything you can
imagine. It's like the Yankees and Red Sox
in the seventh game of the LCS or something.
I mean, it's just the animosity, the tactics,
the speed, the strength, the damage, the bruising.
So, here's a sport that's obviously found
some sort of unlooked for, unexpected national
success. It's attracted a fair amount of media
attention. There's a Drew Barrymore movie
which I actually thought was pretty good,
I was pleasantly surprised I guess I would
say. But yet, what is really, what I found
really special about it, which is the, this
sort of grass roots manifestation of sports
for that basically attracts people that were
never involved in sports before, it kind of
gets pushed to the wayside. And they're definitely
wrestling with, with what sort of television
coverage they want, what kind of media coverage
they think is appropriate, what sort of level
of sponsorship or involvement with outside
financing they can deal with while continuing
to maintain control of the sport at sort of
grass roots nature. So I think that there
comes a point where it's a fine line.
I mean, you know, I don't think that, I don't
think the guys at the Trans Iowa really need
to worry about this issue so much, but I think
that, you know, when something like roller
derby or bike polo, which is another sport
that's gone from being, you know, a scrappy
sportplayed by about 15 people around the
country, to having a very recognizable core
of national or international support. Eventually,
it gets to the point where you have to say,
"Well, what's going to happen to our sport?
Is it going to become just another part of
the sort of mainstream sports or alternative
sports or extreme sports spectrum, where TV
and corporate sponsorship play a role? Or
do we keep it, or do our best to keep it underground?"
I don't know if there's a right answer to
that question, but there's certainly a time
when a line is crossed. And I think it's about
the time when a player cashes the first check
from Red Bull.
Anything else? All right, seeing none. Thanks
very much and thanks a lot.
[applause]